>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
I'm very pleased to
see you all here.
My name David Plylar and
I'm a music specialist here
at the Library of Congress.
And I'm just going to
speak to you a little bit
about the program that
we have tonight.
And maybe just to show you
a few little insights into--
in particular, into one of the
holdings of the management holdings
that we have at the Library which
is the first manuscript version
of Brahms Handel variations,
the Variations
and Fugue on a Theme by Handel.
So, I have some images of that up
later towards the end of the talk.
So, firstly, there's something in
common with each of these pieces,
well, most of the pieces
that you're going to hear
in tonight's performance.
They all heavily draw on
the tradition of fugue,
one by one of the, you know,
the person that we always think
of with the fugue and we
associate with the fugue, JS Bach.
And then others who kind of
followed in that footstep--
in his footsteps so with essays in
the genre that are kind of battling
with the same sorts of issues
that Bach was dealing with in his
but then, taking them
in different directions.
So, I thought we would start by
just talking a little bit about--
if I can get this correct--
the fugal system.
There are lots of politics
in music especially the types
of words that we use.
We talk about mastery of form
and wanting to master the fugue.
And fugues have often have
this sort of academic,
like the highest aspiration for
composers that they want to able
to compose a fugue well, and
they want to be the masters
of the subject with all the answers,
showing off at an exposition,
in their exposition, swiftly
dealing with any episodes of kind
of unruly musical characters,
and often finding different ways
to augment their reputation
especially
by start doing their stuff
towards the end of the fugue.
So, I apologize.
You're going to be
in for tonight but.
But how does one manage
this and how does one strive
to master these types
of things historically?
Those are questions that we
might just hint at tonight
but we're not going to try to tackle
because they're very
large types of questions.
So, in the feudal system-- fugal
system, I'm sorry, you know,
many people, their eyes glaze
over when you start to get
into the details of
fugal structures and--
so, we're not going to do that here.
So instead, we're going
to look specifically
at where fugues have trod.
Like what types of
things are we talking
about when we speak of a fugue?
Is it the structure of a fugue
that gives its identity as a fugue
or is there rather a
collection of traits
or is it some combination
of these things?
[ Laughter ]
There is no real perfect
example of what a fugue is.
Often, it's described as having an
exposition and having other sorts
of development of qualities
going through episodes
and then coming back to some sort
of summation and a sort of a return,
in a way that's somewhat
similar to a sonata.
But, what I would rather
focus on as a listener,
especially if you're a listener
who's hearing a particular fugue
for the first time is how is
it that we tend to approach it?
And there's lots of
different ways and different--
everybody has a different
approach to it.
But it's basically-- it's
dependent on the material
that a composer is using, the actual
composer, the particular traits
of that composer, and the time on
which the composer is writing in.
Another factor that we're
going to look at in particular
with the fugues that we're going
to hear today is their location
with respect to the rest of
the music in the program.
They have basically a locus ultimus.
They're the last thing
that you hear in each work.
And I'm talking about the
preludes and fugues in Bach
from the first book of
"Well-Tempered Clavier."
It's not fugues and preludes,
it's preludes and fugues.
So, they're kind of these pairs
where the fugue is the point
where you're going towards.
And then in the Beethoven,
the fugue comes
at the end with some modifications.
And the same with the Brahms,
the fugue comes at the end.
But all of them exhibit
certain traits that tend to come
through quite clearly and these
deal with issues of variation
that we find in other types
of [inaudible] strategies
in non-fugue works.
One thing that I do notice
when I'm listening to a fugue
and I'm just thinking in the
abstract here, that I think in terms
of voices, like usually
there's a presentation
of a single idea that I listen to.
And then I think of them
in terms of layering.
I may not know at what pitch
level is going to come in next
or something like that, I might
have an idea, but I'll get the sense
that it's another voice
that's being layered onto it.
I also get a sense that there's
a limited number of ingredients
that are going into the
mix that are contributing
to this musical composition
that I'm hearing.
But generally, this is the case,
not always the case especially
in very complicate fugues.
So, if there is no single real
definition or defining fugue type
that we can look at, what
do we get when we have--
what can we do about this smaller
versions of fugues that tend to come
up such as the fugato
and the fughetta.
There's not much that we can
do except to say-- I'm sorry--
that there are attempts to
describe the process of the types
of imitation and things that
composers employ at specific moments
to emulate a strict contrapuntal
style or maybe not so strict,
just depending on these types of
ingredients that they might use
that we might recognize
in a fughetta passage.
It might be in versions,
stretching the themes out a bit
through what's called augmentation,
contracting them a bit,
through diminution, all these
different types of things
that we can still somehow
identify it either
as more typically significant
or having the similar sort
of overarching form to it, shape
to the phrase, shape to the motive.
Still assuming like it's
very much a part of it.
But specifically looking
at tonight's and we won't--
don't worry, we won't be
spending a ton of time
with keys and stuff like that.
But there is-- the way that the
program is constructed is really
nice, I think, and
augmentatious, as I put it.
We have what is essentially
a kind of one way
of putting these different
preludes and fugues in order
that is not the way that you see
it in the "Well-Tempered Clavier."
So, when Bach first was putting
these together and did the fair copy
in the 1722, the way
that it was ordered
in terms of keys is progressive.
That is, it gets start with
C and then we move to--
we move up chromatically
until we get to B. It's a--
It's not maybe the way that you
would encounter it in performance
and in fact, you probably
would not have encountered it
as an entire block in a performance.
So, oftentimes, what is--
pianists have their opportunity
or keyboardists I should say
have the opportunity to put them
in particular orders that make
sense, and this one does to me.
And we'll listen a little bit
to hear why it might
make sense as well.
So, in this case, we start with
A-flat major and then if we go
down a fifth-- I'm
calling it a fifth--
that would give us D-flat major.
But then, we'll give it the minor,
well, so, say, D-flat minor.
And then, we'll enharmonically
change that to C-sharp minor.
So, it kind of works out as a fifth.
And then if we go down, if you
give me that, we go down a fifth
from there to F-sharp major, and
then if we take the relative minor
of that as D-sharp minor
which is the key of the fugue,
we have the same key
signature for that.
When that ends, it's spelled as
D-sharp major, but it sounds--
we'll hear it as E-flat major which
then leads directly to A-flat major
which is the key of the Beethoven.
That sounds complicated
but it sounds very easy
when you actually just
hear it to the ear.
So, I'm wondering just to-- so we'll
get a sense of what this sounds
like without listening
to very much of them.
Can we start with disc one,
play the opening of disc two
and I'll just signal when to change
and it will be skipping by one.
So I'll-- two.
Disc one of track two.
Yeah.
[ Music ]
OK. Well, the point is made.
E-flat going to A-flat.
And a brilliant point
it was, I'm sure.
So, we'll just move right
on to the second half
which is a slightly different
way of looking at it.
We have E-flat going to G-minor,
to A-minor, to B-flat, to B-flat.
What's happening here is that
we have another leap of a fifth,
E-flat to B-flat, relative minor
as the same key signature G-minor,
and then we're just oxalating
about that kind of B-flat axis
and then ending on B-flat
because we want to affirm B-flat
as the key of the evening.
That was a joke there.
But, I think we'll
forgo playing this.
But when you're listening,
just, you know, you'll get--
I believe it's going to be
playing them straight through so
that you'll start to hear
some of this relationships
that might be of interest to you.
At the time when Bach
was writing it, it was--
we call this the "Well-Tempered
Clavier."
Tuning is not the same as it was--
as it is today and is
continuing to change today.
Lots of people have a lot more to
say about this in greater detail
than I can, except to
say that back in the day,
keys had a lot more distinctive
character than they do
in the cases of equal temperament.
And so, this was one of the
things that was being explored
with all these new keys,
especially the ones
that had some strange key signatures
that were not typically seen
for Bach, the "Well-Tempered
Clavier."
So going back to the A-flat major
prelude, we'll just take a look
at a couple of things from the
Bach that will kind of stand
for everything because there's
not enough time to really go
into detail on all these pieces.
So, we're not looking
at a fugue in this case,
we're looking at a prelude.
And this one I think
is a great opener
because it gives us a very
clear sense of relationships
that we can hear right away.
So in this case, I've
labeled X and Y,
two ideas that are
very much similar.
They're just transpositions.
A little bit altered but then
you can follow the rhythms
as being pretty much the same.
And then, you can see that the same
basic thing happens with X and Y.
In fact, the exact same thing
happens in the left hand,
an octave below as what
we heard in the first.
So, maybe we can hear
this as track one of that.
Just the opening.
[ Music ]
So, you can hear quite clearly that
these are kind of imitative things
and it's a way to build larger
phrases with these smaller ideas.
This continues in many--
with great--
Bach continues this
process with great economy.
And we find that he-- I just
picked out instance among many just
to demonstrate the point.
And these are two spots that
are distant from each other
by about 15 or 16 measures.
But what you'll notice
is that I've labeled X
and Y as that same basic idea
that we just listened to.
We hear it in the base, on the
first, the one that's in the left.
And then we hear it in
the treble on the right.
There's also certain
consistencies that you'll find
between little kind
of many imitations.
Those are the dashed brackets
that show F to A-flat to F, and G,
B-flat, G. You can see that on each,
the upper and the lower is there.
And then-- And the same on the other
one, you can see there's B-flat
to D-flat to B-flat, and C to
E-flat to C. So these are things
that you hear them at slightly
different times, but they're kind
of little many imitative ideas.
And then we have what I'm calling Z,
which here represents just a little
figure that has a neighbor note.
In this case, the first one
is E-flat to D to E-flat.
That happens to be a small or second
than the one that's F to E-flat
to F, but it's still just to--
it's rhythmically recognizable
and the direction in contour
are recognizable to the ear
without having to label it Z.
You know, that's the Z idea.
No, that's not the point
of this kind of analysis,
but it's just a way of
saying that is something
that gives the piece
consistency or gives--
makes references that we
can easily understand.
Time flies though so we've
got to look at the next piece
which is the Beethoven
Opus 110-- I'm sorry.
We're skipping the rest
of the Bach for now just
because there will be the eight--
total of eight pieces in
the preludes and fugues,
the four there are selected.
Beethoven's Opus 110 A-flat
major sonata was written
about the time a little
bit concurrently
with this last piano sonata.
This is his penultimate sonata.
It-- Kind of, it's a step
back from-- in terms of--
it has this air of
simplicity without being simple
from what he had done
before if we look at say
like the Hammerklavier's Sonata Opus
106 which was just I think a year,
a year and a half previously
to the A-flat major composed.
Before we look at briefly at
how he deals with the fugue,
I just want to point out that at
this point in Beethoven's life,
regardless of the state
of his hearing,
he still has this exceptional
ability
to orchestrate at the keyboard.
And I make the statement
about Beethoven,
but it may as well be saying it
about every other composer
on this program.
It doesn't matter-- When I say
orchestrating at the keyboard,
I don't mean to say like
these are the trumpets,
these could be the strings or one
could do that and that's fine.
But, I mean that they treat
the different registers
and the different types of
sound that one can achieve
at a given keyboard instrument in
ways that are totally significant
and dramatically significant.
So, I just picked one example among
many where Beethoven does this.
You can see those little pickup
chords, the little grace notes
that precede B2 or the first measure
there, and then they can kind
of continue through that
second measure that you see.
Those have to kind of fill
out the sound in those spots.
But then, he abandons
them and continues up to
that top note without any support.
Now, he might have chosen to do
octaves or something like that.
But it's not-- for him, it wasn't
just a question of building sound,
it was building a particular
type of sound.
And what we end up hearing when
you have just a single pitch
at that greater remove from the
base is a very unique sort of sound.
So, that's just something to
listen for in these pieces.
It's just the way that they--
these composers treat sound
is a very thoughtful one.
Of course, we know that with
Bach especially with Brahms,
but at the same time,
it's worth pointing
out because those are
the kinds of details
that really give life
to the music I think.
When we look at the
fugue, it comes into play
in an interesting way in the sonata.
Ostensibly, the work is on three
movements in terms of what you see
on the page but really, it's
divided into many further.
Well, it may not further but some,
it depends on how you parse it.
So, you have the first movement
and then you have this
characteristic of second movement.
And then you have this like
adagio and recitative kind
of vocal quality type of
improvisatory passage that leads
to this very beautiful arioso,
theme kind of a lugubrious kind
of passage in a whole section.
And this section leads directly to
the first presentation of the fugue.
And he marks it Fuga.
Maybe we can play--
this is track 11.
[ Music ]
So, I wanted you to hear that
transition that leads into it first.
That's the end of the arioso.
We didn't have time to hear the
full thing but we will a little bit.
And now, compare that
with this really, I think,
just a kind of a magical
but simple moment that leads
to the return of the fugue.
But this time, it's in version.
He even labels it such
so that we don't miss it.
[ Music ]
I wanted to let that
play on just a little bit
so that you could hear how little
tiny ideas start to get parsed
and then get reinvented and
turned into something else.
They're-- Which is a very
a bit of anything to do
but it's also a very
fugal thing to do.
It's part of what this is about.
Building something out of
something that's recognizable
but can have many different
types of utility.
What's, of course, the most
obvious difference about this
versus say though, the Bach fugues
that you'll hear preceding
the Beethoven is the way
that it's split now
into, at the easiest way
of looking at, four
different sections.
So we have the arioso then we have
initial presentation of the fugue.
Then we have a return to the arioso
and a much more impassioned form.
And then a return to the fugue
with the, in this case, inverted.
And then, some people think
that it's-- you might call it,
at the very end, a different
thing because it moves
out of fugal textures but it's
still basically the summation
and there's an arch to it.
And that's going to be important
with Brahms too is understanding
this arch that people are going for.
So it becomes less about just making
some sort of academic statement
as it is about making some
sort of a musical journey
in helping the listener
to appreciate it.
So, moving ahead, 40 or so years,
we get to the-- I'm sorry--
we get to the opening of the
Brahms Handel variations.
This manuscript dates from 1861.
And at this point, it's not
exactly named in a way that we know.
It's just the Variations and
Fugue on a Theme by Handel.
Instead, it says Variationen
für eine liebe Freundin.
So, this is for Clara Schumann.
Yeah. I'm sorry.
Yeah. So the-- who had--
who performed it and--
but not exactly up to Brahms
level of expectations.
Brahms also played this for
her but Clara had to do it
in difficult circumstances
where she had a limited amount
of time to actually perform.
I think she did both of
the piano quartets as well,
but definitely Opus 25 which comes
right after the set of Opus 24.
And she learned these pieces
very quickly and, of course,
eventually did a very good job with
them but it cost this small falling
out for a brief period of time.
Brahms at this point is 28.
So, he's already accomplished a
lot but he's not quite at the level
where he's got the great kind
of recognition that he wants
for himself and to-- I don't mean
that in terms of public recognition
but I mean it in terms of feeling
that he has complete
command of what he's doing.
And this is getting back to that
idea of mastering one's art.
So one way to do that is to kind
of, you know, deal with the past
by encountering the forms and Brahms
does this repeatedly throughout
his career.
You know, one of the most famous
examples being the finally movement
of the fourth symphony where it
takes on a passacaglia and kind
of creates this great movement
out of it which is, you know,
it's interesting because it's--
it is an achievement but it's also
in some ways, it's an
easy way to have some sort
of basic structure
that you can work with.
And something similar is happening
with the Handel variations.
And what I mean by that is that
the theme itself which is an aria
from a sweet, that Handel composing,
he actually wrote in
the same key B-flat.
And he composed I think
five variations
on this aria in that original sweet.
It has the same basic periodic
structure and Brahms maintains
that almost without exception for
the entire duration of the work.
So, when we look at it
here, we're just setting
that Brahms has here just that you
see the theme at the beginning.
It's basically four
measures repeated.
And then, a second group
of four measures repeated.
And it's quite ornamented
but we see right away
that Brahms embraces
this ornamentation
in a way that's very different
than the way that Handel did.
So, if we just look at the
particulars of towards the end
of Variation One in the Handel
versus the end of Variation One
in the Brahms, I'm not
meaning to say one is better
than the other or anything
like that.
First of all, they're
quite, you know,
distinct in so many different ways.
But rather that they treat the
material, you can still see
that they're kind of engaging in
the same argument but already,
Brahms is moving quite a bit away
and emphasizing those details
like the ornamentation and whatnot.
So, one of the great pleasures of
being able to look at autograph--
holograph manuscripts by
composers who we can't speak
to now is we get a
window into their process,
and this particular piece
offered us a few options.
I was able to look-- to meet with
Pierre-Laurent Aimard yesterday
to talk over a number of these
different changes that were made
to the score, and it was just
a great pleasure to be able
to look at this in detail.
Because it's not always just, you
know, once you have a fair copy
which is what this basically is,
it's pretty much a done piece.
And so, composers will sometimes
put in different dynamic markings.
Maybe change a tempo here or there.
I think actually on
the previous-- oops--
in the previous, this first
page, you can see that, you know,
he has put in a second ending
in pencil at the very end
on the bottom right
side of the screen.
You can kind of see that pencil.
He would do this throughout this
and it's just a way of saying,
I need to do something
differently to transition
between movements or
between variations.
But sometimes, they become
a bit more significant.
I'm just going to point
out a couple of this.
But just because I think
it's an interesting thing.
And I think it's important to
see these as living documents
and not just, you know, these
notes on the page that I've come
down from ages past that, you know,
these are things that were workable
and then, you know, Brahms might
have changed his mind later.
In fact, he did in certain cases.
So, at the end of Variation
Eight, at the very top right--
I don't know if you
can see it too well.
But what you should see is some
pencilled-in notes underneath
on the top right.
Basically, those are-- he originally
had just same repeated notes
in the left-hand, I
keep going on and on.
But instead, he decides
to have them go
up an octave and up another octave.
This is the kind of
orchestrational decision
where it doesn't change the harmony.
It just doesn't change
that sort of a thing,
but it does change the affect
and the motion of the piece.
So that's one example
of a type of change.
Another major example is
changing the order entirely
of the variations.
It's been said of this piece
and other variation sets
that sometimes you can just-- you
could just arbitrarily take them out
and put them into a different order
and no one would be the wiser.
And maybe that's true, in
certain cases, each one--
each variation is sort of an--
a clear set idea onto itself,
that's absolutely true.
But there's also this very clear
directionality that is dealt
within particular ways that
are more or less effective.
And Brahms sensed this
when he was looking
at this particular
sequence of variations.
So, coming out of Variation 14,
you have this very strong movement
and use of sixth in the right hand
especially, you'll kind of see
at the top of the page, you'll see
those sixths going back and forth.
What happens when-- I'm not
sure how practical this will be.
This will be on these
two by the way.
What happens is that you start to
get a sort of back and forth thing
if you're not careful about how you
handle the order of the variations.
So, the way that Brahms
had it originally--
We'll just hear a little
bit of that.
I'm not sure if this will work.
But starting in track 15,
this would be Variation 14.
[ Music ]
I'll come back to that shortly.
That was just a snippet from each
of these four variations
in their original order.
Now, one of the things that
we see, and that's going
on to the 17th Variation.
In the new ordering,
Brahms takes advantage
of what he'd actually
originally written.
So we have those sixths that I
pointed out just a moment ago.
This is at the end of Variation 14.
Then we have this, what I'm
referring to in the title there
in terms of the hunting which is
basically interval contraction
and expansion.
You'll often hear this but because
of the way the horns were tuned,
where you have as you go
higher, you get closer together.
And so you might start with
an octave then fifths and,
you know, getting smaller.
So we have a third at the top
and then coming back down.
In this case, you have the
reverse at the end of Variation 14,
and that's the part I've labeled
in the second measure interval
contraction and expansion.
Then, if you go directly
into the new Variation 15,
you see that you get the tonal
inversion of that material,
and that's also labeled--
that's labeled now interval
expansion and then contraction.
So, you start to have this
actual-- it was already there.
He'd already written the
variations in that particular order,
but this brings out a
particular relationship
and especially the thirds and sixth
which are also inversions
of each other.
If you have a sixth and you
put this sixth underneath,
it turns into a third.
He takes advantage of that in a way
that makes the variations move
together a bit more smoothly.
Additionally, it has the
advantage now of ending perfectly
into Variation 17-- I'm trying
not to get this confused.
To where-- With the new
end of Variation 16,
it leads very smoothly
into variation 17.
So, instead of talking
about that ad nauseum here,
why don't we just listen to that?
So this will be starting
from 15 and we'll just listen
through to the beginning of 18.
[ Music ]
So when you hear without
that delayed,
it does move in smoothly
into that new variation.
So those types of decisions
are made at various stages
in the compositional process.
And these cases are
fairly late stage.
It's just important to
note and interesting
to consider what it would have
been like if you hadn't done that.
I don't think that people
would have thought less
to the piece to be honest.
But at the same time, one
has the sense that, yeah,
that seemed like the right move.
Sometimes, you find an earlier
version that composers do
and you think, wow, I wish that he
or she just kept it the way it was
because that was kind of maybe,
a little bit more effective.
But, this is kind of one of the
fun things about being able to look
at these older manuscripts.
Some of these changes that
composers make don't make it
into the final version.
So, it's not always-- you know,
when you look and talk about urtext
and like this final
word kind of volumes
that people put together these days
which are important in their own way
for sure, they don't always
embody some very interesting ideas
that the composer might have
put down at the beginning.
And this is one that was just
pointed out to me yesterday
in that talk which is that at the
top here and measure-- I'm sorry--
at Variation 21, you have--
he wrote in Pizzicato.
And he's pointing to
the grace notes.
And why is this important?
Because it's an orchestrational
detail.
He doesn't mean you're going to
reach in and pluck the string,
although that would be impressive.
And I have to say, I don't dare
any pianists to take that on
but what's important about
that word with respect
to the grace notes is that's where
you get the thematic reference.
The theme is in the grace notes.
So he's saying, there's a
color choice that you can make
in the way-- or the way that
you articulate those grace notes
that would allow it to
sing it in a particular way
that makes it-- the
theme more clear.
So, those types of things
are very interesting I think
to be able to see.
And then, that's what
we can learn form this
that you won't find
in a modern edition.
Sometimes you do as footnotes
but not all the time.
Another case that I think is
worth-taking note of is that the way
that a composer writes especially if
it's handwritten is very evocative
of what they might be asking
for in the music itself.
That's not always true.
There's plenty of passionate
music that looks
about as stayed as one can have it.
But there's this passage work
that is leading to the final fugue
in the Brahms where he-- clearly,
it starts to have this sweep
to the way that he's writing.
And you can see this especially
in the Variation 24 at the bottom
of this page, but also leading
into it from the Variation 23
which is very much the same type of
material, just a slightly different.
And all I'm referring to really
are just the way that it looks.
It matches the way that it sounds.
Let me think-- what's
that-- that's going to be--
Can you play just the
beginning of track 25?
[ Music ]
So you get the sense of sweep, the
sense of motion and you see this
and there's other material
that has a certain similarity
to this earlier in
the variation set.
But it's not-- it doesn't
have the same sort
of handwriting signature
that this does.
One can read too much
into that, of course.
You might have been just getting
tired and just ready to be done
with it because at this point,
it was just copying it out to.
So it wasn't like in the midst of
the compositional process probably.
But it is something
that you tend to see
and it's another interesting
component.
When we get to the fugue,
there's an interesting kind
of moment that's reminiscent to me
or Schumann, especially Schumann
of the Symphonic Etudes,
the 25th Variation here.
And all I want to point
out about the fugue here,
because it's a big fugue,
it's a good five minutes or so
and it's a great closer, is that you
start to see again the same types
of techniques that are being used
by both Bach and Beethoven before.
Namely, taking a small cellular
idea and then expanding it
to produce a larger phrase, and
then using those cellular ideas
as accompanimental
[phonetic] figuration.
Just like in the Bach in the
A-flat prelude, it wasn't a fugue
but there's that little turn idea,
that neighbor note idea that was--
that went back and forth
that was a little snippet
that was already recognizable
when you'd hear.
You have the same exact thing here,
almost verbatim just
inverted in the Brahms.
And so that starts to be used.
You can see-- Well, it's-- it
will be better just to hear it
when we get to it and just
hear how they're put together.
The other point I'd like to
make about the Brahms' fugue
in particular and, it also applies
to the Beethoven and to some
of the Bach fugues as well,
is that of the issues--
it starts to become a drama-- a case
of what is important dramatically
to the music to push things forward.
And Brahms at this point, I feel
that there's a great sense of ease
with which he writes
this fugue that it feels
like this is exactly what it needs
to be for him and it encompasses him
as a pianist, as well as a composer.
And this was I think one of the
most important moves for Brahms.
Because as a pianist,
he was able to kind
of make the fugue his
own in this way.
So what you'll hear are
figurations and different types
of sonorities put together with
the recognizable fugal elements
that start to take on
a life of their own,
as almost like their own
little cellular motivic ideas
that could even be sort
of like a textural subject
or something like that.
I'm not saying that he treats it
exactly in a sort of academically
that way, but you do
start to get that feeling.
And eventually, you start to
forget about the fact that you're
in the midst of this kind
of learned composition
and just hear it as music.
And I think that that's also
something that I suspect happens
to a lot of us when we listen to
a fugue, is that we kind of think
at the beginning, OK, there's
a voice and there's an answer,
and then it comes back maybe at the
same pitch or something like that.
And we follow it through this
exposition, but at some point,
we start to just appreciate the way
that these voices are interacting
in a way that just
makes for great music.
So with that, I'd like to just
go ahead and close and be happy
to take any questions
you might have.
And if you could just wait for--
>> Do, we, musicians, you know, go
through these pieces the way you did
with different versions of the
same piece by the composer?
>> David Plylar: Was the question
do musicians go through them?
>> Yes.
>> David Plylar: Yeah.
>> The way you did.
>> David Plylar: Yes.
It just depends on the person
and the access that they have.
So, one of the issues is that,
you know, often, we have our--
we might have a version of the piece
that we have back home that we used,
you know, when we were kids
maybe or something like that.
And eventually, you start to look
for other editions maybe edited
by different people who you admire.
But if you're at a professional
level and you're performing,
you tend to want to make
your own decision as much
as you can especially when dealing
with these particular
types of pieces.
And so, oftentimes, performers--
there are performer
scholars that will go through
and do their own research and
they're-- I think that what they--
and, of course, I can't speak
for anybody but I do think
that there is a sense in which
they arrive at the conclusion
that here's a way that I
want to present this music
that I believe is faithful to
an idea that was perhaps held
by the composer but not necessarily
fidelity to a particular text.
And just like I was
saying with the Brahms,
you have all these notes here
that are in Brahms handwriting
that did not make it
into a final edition.
So, OK, maybe he though better
of it and took it out later.
But there is something about
maybe an idea that are kernel
of something that is worth-keeping.
And so, I think it's up to each
musician to make a decision
about what they'd like to do.
And last thing I'd say about that
is that, you know, one of the goals
of libraries and other
institutions is to try to make--
the people who or the institutions
that hold these manuscripts is
to try to make them as available
to those people as possible.
And so for instance, this
particular manuscript,
anybody here can go online to
our Performing Arts Encyclopedia
and take a look at it yourself
and you can download images.
Now, we don't have all of
our manuscripts up that way
but that's an-- a way to make
them accessible to others.
>> All right.
>> David Plylar: I think
we have another question.
>> Is there any handout
left in the fugue?
>> David Plylar: It's hot.
It's too hot to handle
so I couldn't--
well, but then I'm sorry but, no.
Oh, go ahead.
>> How long did Brahms worked
on manuscript for this?
And, well, over what timeframe?
>> David Plylar: You know what,
I don't know exactly the answer
to that by I know that he
was-- it finished in 1861.
I think it was relatively quick but
I don't want to say it incorrectly
because he-- it's dated September
1861 which was the birthday
of Carla Schumann was in that month.
So, I have a feeling it was in
the months just preceding that.
I'm not sure.
Is there another question?
We have another one.
>> Sure.
>> David Plylar: Just one moment.
>> Thank you.
I have a question out
of complete ignorance.
Is the fugue the only structure in
which a theme, single theme is taken
and repeated and kind of varied
on, oh, as opposed to beginning
at some point and ending in another,
it's-- is that true of the fugue?
>> David Plylar: Well, that's
actually a great and something
that I could have been
much clear about.
That's a very good question.
To answer it quickly, I would
say that if you take an idea,
a musical idea, you
can do lots of things
to that musical idea
especially in a tonal context.
So, you can turn it upside down, you
can lengthen it, you can shorten it.
To do that, you can do that
with any piece of music.
So, sonatas, that's what
a lot of composers do.
They have-- They'll present material
and they'll present contrasting
material with it perhaps,
there might have-- it'd
be accompanied or not.
And then, they'll tend to
develop it in some way.
And that idea development
is where a lot
of these different components
come into play like the imitation.
And so, it's not just the preview
of kind of fugal academic wiring.
It's just that in a few, there
tends to be a particular sequence
of things that one expects to
find in that expository section.
So you have a subject that's
presented, it often is pretty short.
And then, you'll have kind of
an answering to that subject
which is basically a
transposition of that same material
at a different level,
usually a fifth above
or depending on the situation.
And then-- So there's-- But like
I said, there's no single way
that a fugue is constructed.
There's also no single way
that a sonata is constructed.
And you still have people writing
sonatas in very different ways.
In some ways, it's
almost the sonata by fiat.
They say it's a sonata
so it's a sonata.
[ Laughter ]
With the fugue, it's a little harder
to do that because at some point,
you'll say, well, I don't
hear any, you know, imitation
or something like that but.
So, I hope that kind of
answers a little bit.
But it applies to lots
of different things.
Is there another question?
>> This may be too hot to
handle too but I was wondering
about the performers on the
recordings that we heard
and the examples, and
ones that you--
maybe new people that you think
are good at interpretation.
>> David Plylar: I will
tell you who you heard.
I think I'll stay away
from the other.
The Bach that you heard is from
Pierre-Laurent Aimard's new CD
that was just released in August.
And he has the entirety
of Book One on it.
Again, there's another
discussion that's worth happening--
happening and interesting to have
about, you know, choosing to play it
on a piano versus another
type of instrument
and those types of things.
But pianists tend to play in
piano so that why I chose that.
The Beethoven's Paul Lewis who
was here a couple of years ago.
And the Handel, I'm just-- The
Brahms, I may actually just blanking
on but it's a different pianist.
So, I apologize for that but.
So, sorry-- Yeah but I've-- yeah.
I think we have time for one
more question if there's anybody?
There's one up here.
>> It seems to me a few years
ago at the Freer Gallery,
I remember hearing the Brahms,
but it was two-pianists,
it was Emanuel Ax and a woman--
>> David Plylar: Maybe--
>> And I'm wondering, did the
Brahms recasts this several times?
>> David Plylar: I think
in the Haydn variations.
>> Oh. OK.
>> David Plylar: No, no, because he
did a two-piano version of that one.
>> OK. OK.
>> David Plylar: Yeah, which is
also a great piece, yeah, yeah.
We can take one more
if there's one more.
But there doesn't have
to be one more, does it?
[ Laughter ]
We'll, thank you-- Oh,
well, one more, OK.
One more.
>> You didn't go into the origins
of the fugue and most people I think
in the most elementary way think of
it as developing out of the round.
And here, I know I do, I hear
the round in almost every fugue
and that's the way I approach it.
Could you talk a little
bit about that?
>> David Plylar: That's a very
complicated issue and there's--
so there's a history going way
before Bach's time in terms
of what-- where a fugue comes
from, things like the Ricercar,
all these other types
of predecessors.
But ultimately, what they're founded
on and I think it'd be better
to look to somebody who's more of
a scholar in that area than I am.
But ultimately, what they're founded
on are relationships between ideas
of counted point and
imitation on those types
of things and imitative behaviors.
So, certain types of rules
start to develop over--
when I say rules, I'm not saying
necessarily written-down rules
but just rules that tend
to work in practice.
Over time, those develop and
eventually become codified
by different theorists at
different points thinking
of the Gradus ad Parnassum or
things like that where, you know,
people are trying to come to
grips with what's happening.
Not necessarily providing
a groundwork for what--
how people should produce.
But eventually, you
do get that as well
and so there's this
lengthy process development
that is not a singular
branch on a tree, I think.
I think that there are lots
of different approaches that--
and even today, you know,
people still write fugues.
But it's, you know, maybe most
of them tend to be traceable
to the 18th Century in terms
of where they're coming from,
in terms of what they
identify as a fugue proper.
But, I think that other
traditions are also represented.
So, sorry, I'm not able
simply address that but.
Well, thank you so much and I hope
you enjoyed tonight's concert.
And I assure you will.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us a loc.gov.